colère et trahisons pour pierre bédier
président du département des yvelines
il dénonce l'attitude de l'entreprise
calcia qui a annoncé la délocalisation
de son siège social dans les
hauts-de-seine sans en avertir le
département nous avons été trahis par
cette société et par des patrons voyous
qui au mépris de la parole donnée au
mépris des engagements pris et au mépris
des salariés de l'entreprise organise un
départ en catimini du territoire sur
lequel il ne laisserait que les
activités polluantes et tout ça pour
mener un plan social qui ne dit pas son
nom puisque un instant où je vous parle
on fait pression sur les salariés pour
les amener à démissionner puisque on les
déménage à plus de 30 km la société
calcia l'intention d'exploiter une
nouvelle carrière dans le vexin et
organise son départ vers rueil malmaison
un événement qui vient fragiliser
l'emploi local et qui attise
l'indignation des élus
en ce qui me concerne la confiance est
tout à fait rompu donc même si on a des
promesses avant le jeudi après midi
moi je rentre maintenant résolument dans
l'opposition acacias parce que ses
promesses même si elle arrive avant
jeudi
elles ne peuvent être que de papier ce
sont des promesses qui engage une
construction industrielle lourde qui
engagent des engagements sur la carrière
lourd et je pense que même si les
prennent pour deux ans pour trois ans
dont 3 en or a le même problème
la confiance est donc rompue pierre
bédier a annoncé qu'il demanderait jeudi
16 janvier une révision du plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal pour interdire
l'exploitation de la nouvelle carrière à
bruyant vexant